we're here with Eric Rosen streamer
International Master
worldwide
photographer just an incredible person
an incredible chess professional wearing
so many hats Eric first of all welcome
to the podcast thank you for accepting
this invitation thanks so much for
having me it's great to be here and I
think we're going to start with um a
game between yourself and Fabiano and
you guys are going to be playing the
Stafford Gambit that is your personal uh
invention is that correct favorite
dubious candidate Yeah it's gotten a lot
of a lot of traction on YouTube and uh
yeah I don't know if I'm prepared for
this but uh we'll see how it goes so
you're going to play a dubious opening
against a 2800 level player yes how do
you see your chances at the beginning of
the game I've played this a lot against
like top level Grand Masters online and
if they're not prepared there's some
like there's still some landmines to
fall into and probably are you prepared
for this no I'm not really prepared for
this you didn't even remember the name
of the opening yeah that's minutes ago
that's um
it's a bit embarrassing it's it's such a
popular opening these days have you
watched my YouTube content I I have yeah
okay I have
let's go I can't I can't say that I'm
like a huge fan of the opening okay good
luck game on boys
if I don't take on C6 will you be very
disappointed I will be if I play Knight
F3 or D4 I mean now you have to accept
again declining the Gambit yeah you have
to set the Gambit all right I gotta take
it you're forced
and Dubai play this against how you find
how you find play Knight of three
slightly disappointed
okay that's I was told you to develop
your pieces keep the pod okay so I see
my G4 is coming queen D4 is coming I'm
very scared okay so I'm going to
defend against Nigeria versus defend
against my G4 okay
Eric is still in theory he's just
there's two moves here I'm debating
which one faking us right now yeah okay
we'll go for this okay now now I'm
actually terrified
actually better I'm genuinely terrified
okay I'm gonna do this see happens
I think you're lost at this point me yes
yeah I must be
okay I'm gonna try to
try to escape try to survive just try to
survive
so the material equality has been
restored it's not a Gambit anymore no
more gambits is that a bad thing for you
or for me it's a bit disappointing I
don't know
I'm out of my prep though
if I want that my Pawn so
should be okay
see big moments right now
I see your threat but what to do
so the threat was actually to go E5 very
nice if I was 98 you know
so now what do we do here
I was very interesting I think it's some
success I'm not losing in the first time
I agree maybe for both of us so
I
agree
yeah I'm I'm also not losing which is
better than I'd hoped for
okay let's just
take the center
play it safe yeah gotta play it safe
okay
I didn't want to trade Rooks but
very classical what choice do I have
classical development
take the center
castle for the king's safety
black on the other hand
playing it still very modern modern
style
this is very modern
okay let's
go after a pawn
I'm struggling on time here quite a bit
it's okay you can still take your time
I'm not sure that you have my best
interests in mind when you say that
so the question is how did you find
everything and castle and get I'm not
comfortable here
difficult situation
back to even on time right now
fobby how do you feel about the position
a little better than I did a minute ago
because now I have
more time which is a
an encouraging site which is very
encouraging yeah
um
Eric can defend the pawn
G7 but with King f8
that's it's an option that's a good move
right there we definitely don't have
each other's best interests
okay I could take upon what do I want I
think I'm going to
ah you did take thanks for the idea
though it did take my advice
interesting
that's well calculated
that was excellent thank you
I think I'm gonna have to reach over
take this
so it's back to me again but yeah it's
back to being again
I don't know why we did that but
always answer A5 with A4 or A4
with A5 that's the um Romanian School of
Chess right there correct
on full display
that rule basically takes you from a
feeder Master to an international Master
Level
that was the one rule I used when I um
made that jump
rookie five
Rook H1 loses
really nice so let's not do that nice
trap
ah playing it safe
looking for that Queen trade
oh no oh no my king oh no my king Ice
King okay good game guys good game yeah
I mean defending uh
yeah pretty dubious which goes to show
the dubiousness of the Gambit Hy was
interesting though I was I was thinking
you would play Queen D4 and Knight takes
E4 but I thought maybe White's a bit
better there
I was actually wondering if I play Queen
D4 instead of H5 and then uh instead of
94 H5
oh yeah yeah this could D3 and not ig4
right right so there's a trap that
instead of D3 after H5 if you play H3
that's not G4 and the G4 is winning
yeah that's I would probably play d39 G4
and take H takes ambition before right
and it's still like plus one for white
yeah so
this is deciding which uh but it looks
scary with open H file so that that one
doesn't look so simple I wonder if um
maybe Knight C3 is not the easiest path
for white maybe D3 first so well Knight
C3 and then H3 is just a simple approach
which so you're you're telling the
secrets of how to refute your opening
yeah I mean they're still there's still
ways for Bach to play for some
compensation but uh yeah H3 is I think
what most
like video YouTubers recommend just as a
simple
what's the highest level that this
Stafford Gambit has been played at
um I mean in a serious event it was
dubov but dubov uh or how you find
didn't accept the Gambit because she
played knife three suffer again but
declined um yeah yes but then it's just
a good Petra for black
yeah
um
it's yeah it seems like it's like you
have the extra tempo
but there's I mean it's mainly played in
like online Blitz and bullets and
compsky lost in like 18 moves and some
title Tuesday with like falling for this
um like Knight G4 H5 okay yeah yeah uh
yeah I could see that happening easily
in Blitz that's only Falls for that yeah
even I played Costino in title Tuesday
and she walked right into this um H5
Knight G4 line
uh that like if white chooses the wrong
move order there's uh there's landmines
okay I'll uh next tile Tuesday I'm gonna
play this stuff I can't wait okay so
that's a promise
uh you'll have to watch my videos on it
because I cover a lot more traps and
that's what I'm gonna do
um yeah like if white plays white can
also play like d3h3 instead of Knight C3
Bishop H3 right
um
yeah but then there is already Bishop
takes F2
is there King E3 there there's King E3
but then castling and it's like some
crazy lines that looks scary people
haven't I guess white can play King E4
rookie at king of three or is that
losing uh yeah that's one of the main
lines like after King E4
I think Queen H4 is a try yeah but King
K or G4 maybe yeah I think objectively
it's drawn by some Perpetual but yeah
but if you get there then probably white
loses that one now yes practically
speaking
all right boys let's get the uh straight
into the pot
are we gonna make a cut here